what up welcome to coffeezilla today
we're covering part two of the nigerian
scammer today
we confront him and ask him why he did
it what
what's in his mind what's going on in
nigeria but before we get into anything
else before we talk about the 10 million
dollar studio which as you can see is
coming together
let me say i saw a disturbing figure on
the internet this may be
the worst thing i've ever seen check it
out
58 of you have not
smashed like and subscribed dude how
many times
does ana anka have to tell you and
subscribe okay
i'm i'm pissed off okay so this october
my goal for october
is to get this number to 50
subscribes need to come up and if you're
not subscribed
you need to leave so that's my big thing
for october
uh we can only write so many wrongs on
the internet but this is definitely
one of them now anyways without further
ado let me just say um
how's this audio sound by the way we
fixed that
i know that was potato for a while it's
getting better it's not i'm not gonna
say it's perfect
but it's getting better the visuals are
getting better
the 10 million dollar studio i told you
guys just patience
oh there it goes it popped again
patience i gotta not
okay sorry i got it up
uh we're coming together slowly but
frankly i could use
um some of your help if you happen to
have some digital 3d work in unreal
engine or anything like that for virtual
sets
uh i could really use you frankly so if
you're familiar if you're a fan of the
show
if you're looking for a side project
during cove um
i could really use it all right that's
it sorry to
rant at you guys for a little bit i know
a lot of you are going to be like haha
video starts at two minutes uh no
everything i just said
was very important so enough of that
don't say that ever again
but anyways let's talk about what we
came here to talk about which is
my confrontation with the scammer so
first things first i tried calling him
like
why didn't you call him i tried he
immediately hung up on me and so i
panicked and i was like oh crap he's
gonna block this number
cause i only had one number for him so i
immediately kind of uh played hardball
i said look you block me i'm going to
the authorities i'm going to
sars the truth is i was bluffing i don't
even know how to get
ahold of stars i wouldn't have gotten a
hold of stars anyway but i just play
we're playing hardball
playing with scammers so i said look you
you go to
go to go to block me i'm gonna go to
sars
boy i said i have screenshot this is
after he hung up on me
he said who's this i said just an
interested
journalist i don't know am i a
journalist i don't know if i am
let's just say i am what scam get so he
plays dumb i sent him some screenshots
he plays dumb no that ain't me what scam
there are no scam going on anyway
liar he establishes himself as a liar
early on in this conversation i just
want to say that
okay he's just playing dumb are you
talking about a bitcoin scam or
something
finally i get to the point i say you
scam people
with instagram investing pages
there's no getting out of it i know
everything it's too late
oh i understand now hahahahaha it didn't
work
bro people were smarter especially when
it comes to bitcoin
press x to doubt i this is a part of the
conversation
i almost skipped by it because frankly
it's like kind of useless because he
just denies
making a lot of money now in some ways
we don't know if he's not telling the
truth here maybe he wasn't making money
on the other hand he lied to us at the
beginning of the conversation
and this is exactly what a scammer would
say if they were
afraid that you were going to go to the
police or report them or anything like
that
of course he's gonna go oh yeah i'm not
i didn't make any money i don't do it
anymore
he says now all he does is he trades
trades online which is stupid as you
guys know
you're not gonna make a lot of money
doing that so he's probably still
scamming that's just my guess but i'm
not going to try to confront him on this
because frankly
i don't think that's a productive
conversation to have instead i try to
turn it
and make it about scams in nigeria in
general and what he thinks about the
morality because my question is
do you guys care that you're scamming
people
so i'll uh scroll down to that part of
the conversation
because right he just kind of denies it
and so i go how deep do these scams go
he's trying to say oh you should check
out this trader i don't care
and so he goes honestly bro i can't
really say but there are a lot of greedy
people out there one thing i can assure
you
as a fact is that everyone you see on
bitcoin on instagram is the scammer
whether the person posted a photo or
commented under that photo okay
true honestly true and so then finally
he's like okay i
i understand how wicked it is to ruin
someone's life through skim okay
so he's kind of confessing a little bit
you know
it's like i understand how weak it is
but then you do it like
what i mean come on body why would you
do it if you know that it's
you're saying it's wicked okay then he
says but why would someone invest with a
stranger in the first place that
promises dubious returns bro
i find it hard to give anyone money
online uh
yeah you find it hard to give people
money online maybe that's because you're
a scammer
so i said i wonder that myself many
times probably because people who do
this are expert schemers and know how to
convince people with social proof
and i show him evidence of that of him
doing that basically tricking people
when i say stuff like this is how people
get trapped they see the social proof
and think it's legit
that's how ponzi schemes make money
like of course this guy i mean if you're
in the industry like
from my side of trying to bust these
guys or you're a scammer
of course you're gonna say well you
can't trust anyone online because this
is the stuff you look at all day
but he's neglecting the fact that most
people are not
like scammers and you know in the
comments section of my last video
i'm gonna have to pull up a few examples
of this but i had a bunch of comments
basically saying that this guy all his
excuses about why he had to do it
they're just lies because we apparently
have a bunch of people
in our comment section that are nigerian
but they basically goes it's sad that a
lot of people support these scammers in
nigeria they're called yahoo boys a lot
of nigerians
don't see anything wrong with it because
they see it as they are taking money
from people that are
rich so it's not bad or anything but
then some of them point out that even
they're like apparently from rich parts
of the country or at least they're
saying that they're saying
they're upper middle class or went to
some really good schools because they
have written
english they've been wealthy and have
been wealthy for a long time
and so the psychology they use here is
just a justification method
mechanism that they can only use with
foreigners nigerians would call bs on
their reasoning
so yeah it's important to include that
as we go forward with this because
like he does he is a little bit slick
here and he's trying to say oh yeah i
totally understand i didn't even make
money with it i don't even do it anymore
i think a lot of uh people in the
comment section from
last video and this video are gonna call
bs on that because i don't believe it i
don't think they believe it
and basically yeah so for a long time
here i'm not even gonna go through all
of them i'm not even gonna give him the
time of day on this because
he's just basically saying the whole
time that i'm i'm not making any money
and then this is pretty funny he goes
can i refer you to the stocks chat room
he's talking about the trader
that he likes he's like can i refer you
so i can get a referral
as if i'm gonna as if we're going to
join he's trying to scam me in
in the conversation where i'm
confronting him
what is this guy doing uh and i was like
yeah
sure just have a few more questions for
you first number one was it the morality
that got you to stop stocks colleges and
fair
david ferris fx or was it the fact that
he wasn't it wasn't working
number two is everyone in nigeria afraid
of sars i've read up on them they almost
seem like
terrorists they just got some sketchy
motivations he laughs at that
i say what he goes stocks college isn't
a scam
david ferris was that's a total lie okay
again
this guy's lying he's been caught
multiple times already in this
conversation lying
but that also is a like stocks college
talks about
needing david ferris for this game so of
course he was scamming he talks about
scamming
but he says david versus was because it
was a fake account of a different
individual and it wasn't working out
because people knew it was kind of fishy
to invest 500
and receive 20 000 in a month again we
don't have any verification of that
there's a saying that sars are actually
angry because they miss the opportunity
to scam in their days so they catch
young boys and collect
money from them you did not hear this
from me and the interesting thing is
that i think there's some
evidence for this of sars being very
corrupt because
multiple people contacted me about it
and they say sars the division of the
police that
tackle robbery but they found out that
it makes no sense chasing robbers and
risking their lives
they simply stop and search youngsters
knowing they could make money easily
this is because they can simply call you
a scammer and most people would believe
and when they catch real scammers they
simply collect as much funds as they can
and release them back into the wild
basically in nigeria you can apparently
stop and search
without a warrant or cause so that's
what's interesting is like he's kind of
right about sars being
a bit of a scam because we've heard it
from multiple people now
and he's saying like look they share it
amongst themselves the government
doesn't pay them as much as they can
make from young scammers or rich people
doing well in the country
like they have a job to catch scammers
bail is their side hustle
which is insane um and then he goes
please
please leave stocks colleges out of this
there this is legit people
dude bro we've got them in dms scamming
people what are you talking about again
i think he's just covering for his buddy
here and he goes that's why i mentioned
greed there are people greedier than you
can imagine that want to get rich quick
their greed leads them to loss of money
not the scammer okay
bravo for the biggest mental gymnastics
in the world
oh it's not my fault they're not losing
money yeah it is your fault so then he
goes
man i'm trying to take time to go into
details for you and i ain't even getting
paid
time is money yo bless me with funds bro
dude
scam into the bitter end bro i'm
probably
broker than you like i don't know what
you're talking about but then our
scammer here actually starts to get
insightful
he goes if you're looking for a business
you'll find a business
if you're looking for a get rich you'll
find a scam
that is actually true there are victims
who they get themselves in these
situations because they are actually
actively looking for a way to get rich
quick and it just doesn't exist and he
goes on there's nothing that can be done
even if it gets exposed he's talking
about nigerian scams people have been
getting scammed since the 1970s check
the history it didn't start overnight
what needs to be reformed is the mindset
of the youths
we have kids in nigeria who are thinking
of scamming because of no money
i saw a 16 year old boy or younger boy
today with an iphone 11 pro max
i knew straight away that it was a
result of a successful scams or fraud
the music in the country promotes scams
the government promotes scams indirectly
through their actions so does the police
and everyone else
it'll make a good story but it'll
introduce more youths into scams if you
choose to go with it
now i disagree with that i think
education is the key i think sunlight
is the best disinfectant so i totally
disagree with him there
but i just follow up like can you
elaborate on that idea that the
government and music promotes scams
and he says youths will figure out that
scammers are really successful and will
indulge in it
they believe they can scam all their
lives without consequence that's the
mindset bro
i believe the only solution is the
reformation of the african people the
reason they scam is that because they
don't know who they are
amongst themselves dude is there anyone
hearing like uh some uh
patriotic music backing here this is a
pretty good speech
[Music]
honestly pretty good speech for a
scammer
therefore it's safe to say that the
government is scamming its citizens
the youths have seen that and they don't
want to be slaves underneath a greedy
government
therefore they decide to attack everyone
and make money any way they can
the youths are only reciprocating what's
being done to them in their country
like yeah
it's not a bad line of reasoning but
it's also
trying to absolve yourself it's clearly
so
self-uh justifying and self-motivated
but i wanted to say i mean he has a
point he says
so uh from within so without worldwide
scams in nigeria is a reflection of
what's really going on in the country
in nigeria everyone scams each other it
baffles me to this date
we'll have to talk to you later i have
to go now and that's uh the conversation
i mean that's that's pretty much it
interesting stuff
i mean i don't know what you guys think
of that how much does the government
shape the scamming culture very
interested to hear what you think
my guess is this will be a polarizing
interview
and let me know what you think in the
comments below and as always don't
forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
soccer
comes along